est à la majorité de ce jeune homme qui
est arrivé sont occultés fc une
obligation tiré de quitter le territoire
et de par ce fait que perdre et
entière de mes équipes au fournil donc
qu'on ne parle pas d'humanité là on
parle simplement de travail et je me
suis dit que c'était pas possible de
perdre un tiers de mes gars au fournil
et donc j'ai pensé il ya plein de choses
à faire et je ne voyais pas du tout
comment je pouvais me battre contre un
une force si forte et
donc les pensées une nuit que dans les
années 80 où on arrivait à faire des
grèves de la faim pour des écrivains qui
était en prison etc mais célibat on
entend aussi quelque chose qu'on entend
plus du tout parler donc je vais faire
une grève de la faim il faut que je pour
me pour prendre sérieux mon problème il
faut que je fasse quelque chose
d'immense et
commencent ils à la grève de la faim les
3 janvier
[Musique]